now I'm gonna watch this video and we I
don't want you guys to watch it with me
in genre because it's heartbreaking by
these Isis scumbags these people are the
scum of this earth
[Music]
flighty so high-level feed the power
check out sponsors and nature's blend
they specialize in premium Ethiopian
black seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the Sunnah
assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are doing well
inshaallah
i love you guys obviously well we all
around the world are affected by the
corona virus and obviously it's told us
to stay at home unless it's essential
myself personally because of my mom not
really feeling well and having certain
symptoms nothing major but recently
finding out that my auntie who had some
issues having difficulty breathing was
taken to hospital and was tested
positive for the corona virus which in
return caused me to do shopping and
other things to help my grandma and my
auntie etcetera which you saw in my vlog
as well and just today which my love
will come out in sha allah maybe as i
watched video maybe next day the
following day my dad's got a bit of a
temperature as well so i've been doing a
bit of running around so i've been
having about and also like for my
in-laws as well but the reason i
mentioned this is just so you guys you
know i'm trying my best to stick to it
on this i'm doing certain things are
essential and since I've been out and
about doing certain things I popped to
the studio and I wanted to do a video
because I feel this is very very
important because at home I didn't have
the equipment and this is a very tragic
tragic moment because we heard the news
in Afghanistan where which I actually
very recently came across in speakers
corner a Afghani Sikh and I was very
surprised took me with a bit surprised
because I was like wow there's Afghani
Sikhs I didn't know and they were like
yeah you know they've been living there
for for some time for some time I'm not
mistaken some may be a couple of
centuries if I'm not mistaken and then
started nan Rasheed done a video which
he highlighted that 25 innocent Sikhs in
their place of worship was massacred now
as Muslims we need to highlight this
issue I wanted to be very vocal about
this because these are innocent people's
lives have been taken I was fun and I
lost the planet Allah says in the Quran
but if you take a single soul is as if
you kill the whole of humanity and if
you save one soul it
save the whole of humanity and this is
very important and profound because at
the end of the day both of the sisters
what we need to understand is that these
are innocent lives and the prophet
sallallaahu seldom he said a protection
so there is different kinds of
non-muslims yeah there are those who
might be combatants so these are if
there is warfare there are combatants
and even those combatants if they come
to the lands of the Muslims and
protection is granted to them by a
single Muslim if I'm in living in the
Muslim lands and a non-muslim combatant
comes and I give him protection nobody
can touch him nobody can touch him let
alone even me let alone the one who is
living under the Covenant of Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala and the Sharia and
protection has been given to that person
yeah
so this is obviously tourists like oh
geezr etc which is a tax that they have
to pay and the Muslim armies and all the
Muslims in general will protect them and
they don't need to join the army yeah
which is a whole separate topic in
itself but these are innocent Sikhs who
are going about their worship their day
to day life when the prophet sallallaahu
seldom went to Medina and they had a
peace treaty with the Jews and the
Christians there was a covenant that was
made same as one might even cut up when
he when he had the Covenant were in
Jerusalem if I'm not mistaken and this
said that the protection is given to
their worship the place of worship yeah
to their rights to their livelihood yeah
and the list goes on now we have maniacs
sadly these people are absolutely vile
animals because they have gone into a
Sikh temple and killed 25 innocent
people for what reason the question that
we need to ask is why why does this one
find the need to go to a place of
worship a place of worship be it they
worship in a lobby they worship in a
statue irrelevant because in Islam we
are told that we can't even make remarks
against another person their deity let
alone go there and kill innocent men
women and children so we need to be very
vocal about this and this is the reason
why I'm doing this video because these
are people who you know there are human
beings brothers and sisters in whom
and we should be very vocal about this
matter and not brush it under the carpet
because what happened that Christchurch
yes what happened at Christchurch and
even we know in India what's going on
with the Muslims in Kashmir as well
Sikhs were being brutal being beaten by
Hindu mobs not all of them well beaten
why because they were looking after
Muslims or something along those lines
yeah now even if the Sikh community
didn't do this I am NOT doing this video
because Sikhs helped Muslims in India
I'm doing this video regardless if Sikhs
were to attack me and my family that's
ever happened but I will still do this
video because allah subhanaw taala says
in the quran speak the truth even is if
it is even if it's against yourself or
your kin what that means is that I have
to speak the truth now I'm gonna watch
this video and I don't want you guys to
watch it with me in genre because it's
heartbreaking I haven't seen it but
let's watch it together in sha Allah
[Music]
[Music]
subong assistants as we can see ourself
what lie is heartbreaking because
imagine that was my mother or my father
imagine imagine we was I don't know
Christian who ever faith you will be you
are just there in your own community
worshiping Allah and I'm really really
like trying my best to hold my tears why
because as well I is very sad what has
these innocent people done for you to
storm in with a gun and massacring
people same as in Christ Church
what is the difference here what were
those innocent worship is doing but
going to worship their Lord that you
come in that the first thing that uncle
said to the shooter was welcome Rafa and
he gets shot in the face and he goes in
there and massacres 52 people and this
happened in Sri Lanka in a church where
churches were blown into pieces by these
Isis scumbags these people are the scum
of this earth so much so the profits are
seldom said wherever you find these
people kill them now you might say well
that's harsh well not really because
these people have cost corruption on
earth since day one they have rebelled
against the prophet of Allah they have
rebelled against the prophet of Allah
let alone anyone and Isis is very
clearly evidently have killed more
Muslims than non-muslims we're not here
to count who's being killed more the
point here is this they are our biggest
enemy I've repeated this and I repeated
over and over and over again because the
far right we'll take this narrative and
push it
Isis is free from Islam and Islam is
free from Isis the processer sternum has
been very clear how to teach and how to
look after how to look after forgive me
how to look after and care for
non-muslims and his behavior was very
clear there is no compulsion in religion
nobody in no way in Islam it is haram
for me to go and force somebody to come
to Islam it is absolutely Haram so these
animals these vile animals who have
destroyed lives has caused robbers and
sisters innocent
it's in our country UK USA wherever they
may be to travel there and destroy their
lives we've seen this we've seen family
members get destroyed we've seen this I
know of many many cases fire my friends
I know many many cases where innocent
people have been brainwashed yes come
join us and destroyed their lives
destroyed their lives and these people
think they're doing something good
The Hunger Allah Allah has destroyed
this group and may Allah destroy them
more and as Muslims all we want to say
brothers and sisters is that to our Sikh
community we are with you if there is
anything as the Muslim community in
these tough times we are together that
if there's anything that we can do we
are open I myself added now I'm open if
there is a fundraiser going on etc we
are here to help the Sikh community full
force whatever you guys need please get
in contact with me because we share your
sorrow and your pain like we did in
Christchurch you shared it with us we
share it with you and afford to share
that with you guys brothers and sisters
I'm not gonna hold you guys much longer
it's very disturbing and heartfelt so to
our Sikh community we ask God Almighty
to give you guys patient and that's
about it
- next time of the sisters from me
assalamu alaikum what a matter I better
care to check our sponsors and nature's
blend they specialize in premium
Ethiopian black seed products their
products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the Sunnah